a long-awaited u.s intelligence report
on the murder of washington post
contributor jamal khashoggi
could be released later today now
president biden says he has read it and
he will be talking to the saudi king
soon about it
the declassified summary will reportedly
single out saudi crown prince mohammed
bin salman
for the 2018 killing of the prominent
critic in turkey
the report the report's release is part
of biden administration's effort to
reset
ties with the kingdom wishes has more on
this story from the white house
a security camera captured the last time
journalist jamal khashoggi was seen
alive entering the saudi consulate in
istanbul in october
2018 where he was killed and dismembered
by a hit squad his fiancee waiting
unknowingly
outside he was my best friend he was the
law
of my life khashoggi was a fierce critic
of saudi leadership
and the murderers were linked to saudi
arabia's crown prince
mohammed bin salman who ruled saudi
arabia on behalf of his father
the king he denied knowing about the
operation to cbs
evening news anchor and managing editor
nora o'donnell
during an interview for 60 minutes how
did you not
know about this operation some think
that i should know
what three million people working for
the saudi government do daily
it's impossible that the three million
would send their daily reports to the
leader
or the second highest person in the
saudi government but in 2018 the cia
assessed that not only did the crown
prince know about the killing
he ordered khashoggi's execution the
murder led to
international outrage former president
trump sanctioned
17 saudis for khashoggi's murder but he
did not broadly punish the crown prince
or saudi arabia a strategic ally
for the united states on the campaign
trail then
candidate biden said that he believed
the crown prince ordered the hit on
khashoggi
and he pledged that under his leadership
the u.s would make saudi senior leaders
pay the price
and make them the quote pariah's that
they are
now as president he will have to balance
that with maintaining a good
relationship with saudi arabia
not only because of the oil and
resources it controls but because it is
a strategic
base in the region and an important ally
in the fight against terrorism
tony complicated situation for the bite
administration weija thank you very much